. So we're starting to kind of wrap up various
partial recounts and vote audits from around
the country.
One came in from Wisconsin, and it's absolutely
hilarious.
In Wisconsin, the Trump campaign paid about
three million dollars for a partial recount.
Now, remember that in Wisconsin, the margin
of victory for Joe Biden was about 20000 votes.
And the outcome of the recount was that Joe
Biden gained 87 votes in total from doing
this partial recount.
So statistically, it changes nothing.
Biden was winning before and Biden is still
winning 87 votes when the margin is twenty
thousand, doesn't really do anything one way
or the other.
But consider that Donald Trump's campaign
paid three million dollars for this partial
recount, three million dollars to find 87
votes for Joe Biden.
That's thirty four thousand dollars per vote
that the Trump campaign paid.
Well, actually, it would be Trump's followers
who donated money for the recounts.
They paid thirty four thousand per vote for
Joe Biden in the end.
Now, of course, the Trump campaign and Trump
himself already have an explanation as to
why the recounts aren't helping Trump.
And it becomes part of the conspiracy theory.
It's almost evil genius if it weren't so stupid
and predictable, which is, listen, if you
recount all of the invalid votes, all of the
illegal votes, all of the fraudulent votes,
then, of course, you're going to get the same
results.
If they counted invalid votes once and then
they recount them, you're going to get the
same result.
Which now brings us to if they knew this,
why did they pay for a recount?
And there are two reasons.
Number one is optics.
And number two is they raised money for recounts,
half of which was used to pay off Trump's
campaign debt.
Remember the fundraising emails that started
going out right after the election saying
donate to stop the count or to start it or
to recount or to file or whatever the fine
print was?
Fifty percent of what you donate, 50 cents
on every dollar will go to paying off existing
debt that Trump's campaign has.
So you raised six million.
You pay three million for the Wisconsin partial
recount and you put three million towards
your campaign debt.
And meanwhile, you insist I'm fighting Joe
Biden's cheating by doing this.
It's like the perfect final scam, actually,
against Donald Trump's supporters.
And this goes to something else that's very
important.
The right doesn't really seem to understand
what voter fraud is.
Or in other words, right wingers seem to think
that elections could be stolen with actual
voter fraud, things like people voting twice
dead people voting, filling out fake absentee
ballots and sending them in that type of thing.
So then they do a recount and the right wingers
are wondering, wait a second, how it didn't
change the results.
The problem is that the real way you steal
an election, this isn't news to many of you.
I know you don't steal an election with voter
fraud.
You steal elections with election fraud.
That means gerrymandering in the first place.
That at the at the congressional district
level, removing mail, sorting machines at
the post offices to slow down mail delivery,
to try to get mail in ballots to miss the
postmark date when you know that it is overwhelmingly
Biden voters that will vote by mail rather
than Trump voters, you steal an election by
organizing voter purges of registered voters,
using algorithms that would more likely hit
Democratic voters than Republican voters.
You do it by closing polling places in Democratic
leaning areas and sowing misinformation about
where and when you're supposed to vote in
those same areas.
None of that stuff shows up in a recount.
Now, fortunately, all of those methods failed
to steal the election from Joe Biden.
But think about the entire trajectory here.
Before the election, it was Trump's going
to win in a landslide.
You had these hot take.
Right wing YouTube are saying Trump could
get four hundred electoral votes.
Trump landslide inevitable.
All that stuff.
Biden wins.
And so they say, oh, it was stolen.
You have.
To count the votes in some places, stop counting
the votes in other places, remember that in
the 96 hours after the election, you had protests
going on at the same time saying stop counting
votes and start counting votes.
Then they say we'll do a recount, OK, but
the recounts change nothing because they recounted
the illegal votes.
So then let's file lawsuits, which they do.
But then when the judges actually ask Trump's
lawyers, are you alleging voter fraud here
in court, they say, no, we're not alleging
that because they know they don't actually
have evidence of that fraud.
So now they are on to the recounts themselves
are bogus.
Instead, we need audits of each vote and we
need state legislatures to send Republican
electors, even if the state appears to have
been won by Joe Biden.
That's where we are now.
That's how far we've come in nearly the month
since the election.
This will have some trajectory to December
14th when the electors vote and then they'll
come up with something new that will get us
to January 20th.
What it will be, I don't yet know.
But we'll continue covering it on our Instagram
page at The David Pakman Show.
Also, follow me on Instagram for very boring
pictures of my Thanksgiving.